great nations do not fight endless wars
donald trump's pitch to make america
great again included a commitment to
rethinking america's interventionist
foreign policy we went from mistakes in
iraq
to egypt to libya to president obama's
line in the sand in syria
each of these actions have helped to
throw the region into chaos
trump's promise to unwind america's
foreign commitments won the vote of some
anti-war libertarians who argued that
while many of his policy views were
odious
foreign policy mattered most donald is
a peacenik practically certainly
compared to the warmongering hillary
on the campaign trail trump attacked
clinton for pushing u.s
intervention in libya as secretary of
state and her 2002 vote in the senate
for the iraq war
any vote that might lead to war should
be hard but i cast it with conviction
almost everything she's done in foreign
policy has been a mistake and it's been
a disaster
trump would prove to be the less
interventionist alternative to clinton
argued historian thaddeus russell in a
2016
interview with reason whenever there's a
dictator or tyrant
we don't like in any part of the world
we are obligated
to remove him trump is the first
president to call [ __ ] on that very
claim
it all began with a dangerous idea that
we could make
western democracies out of countries
that had no
experience or interest in becoming a
western democracy
and in doing so i think he may do great
service for
actual peace believe it or not but has
trump lived up to the
non-interventionist type
i think trump has moved america
considerably closer to peace
at the very same time he's moved us
into more wars so it's a terribly mixed
bag
russell says that trump's rhetoric alone
advanced the non-interventionist
cause he called into question the need
for america
to invade countries to change their
regimes and to stay there
as occupation forces specifically he
called into question the iraq war
obviously the war in iraq was a big
fat mistake we spent two trillion
dollars thousands of lives
we don't even have it we should have
never been in iraq we have destabilized
the middle east
and that was really important historic
and i'm i'm really grateful for that
unfortunately of course no one took him
seriously or they took him extremely
seriously and tried to bring him down
trump isn't the first modern president
to promise an end to foreign
entanglements on the campaign trail only
to double
down on those commitments once in office
candidate barack obama called iraq a
dumb war
that he would end and never replicate we
have to use our military wisely
and we did not use our military wisely
in iraq
obama did temporarily withdraw troops
from iraq on bush's pre-negotiated
timetable
but intervened again a few years later
after isis filled the power vacuum
he also expanded the war on terror into
several new countries and began
personally ordering covert drone strikes
one of which
killed a 16 year old american and
another that killed
at least 13 people headed to a wedding
even george w
bush who started the disastrous wars in
iraq and afghanistan ran
against nation building on the campaign
trail i just don't think it's the role
of the united states to walk into a
country say
we do it this way so should you you know
the american people
want peace scott horton a popular
anti-war podcast
host and author of a book on the history
of the war in afghanistan
agrees with russell that trump's
rhetorical attack on the foreign policy
establishment
helped the anti-war cause it was
necessary for him to destroy the legacy
of george w
bush in order to help to defeat jeb bush
he really got the vast american sort of
tea party republican voters of america
to finally admit that they were wrong to
have supported george bush
but he says trump is too impulsive to be
reliably anti-war
the problem with donald trump of course
is that he's a millimeter deep
he has some instincts but he doesn't
have thinking
really on these things he doesn't
actually really care
it's just a matter of sort of what feels
stupid to him or not
it seems stupid to pour a bunch of money
into the afghan pit but is it something
for him to have real conviction about
and prevent from happening
no trump's wars with the media
democrats and protesters draw daily
press coverage
but just because america's actual wars
aren't on the news every night doesn't
mean they're any closer to ending
trump hasn't invaded any new countries
but he has
ramped up the nearly 19-year long 2
trillion
afghanistan war that's cost the lives of
tens of thousands of afghanis
and more than 3 500 u.s and nato troops
my original instinct was to pull out
and historically i like following
my instincts once they get in there all
the incentives are to keep the thing
going
trump added thousands more troops in
2017
and dropped more bombs and missiles in
2019 than in any previous recorded year
the consequences of a rapid exit
are both predictable and unacceptable
if you look at barack obama and donald
trump both
they come in their first year in power
and immediately they're met
with this full-court press by the
military for an escalation
instead of withdrawing troops from
afghanistan iraq and syria
he vowed to stop publicly reporting
their numbers
we will not talk about numbers of troops
or our plans for further military
activities
the trump administration did strike a
deal with taliban leaders
in late february to wind down the war
within 14 months
if they pledged to prevent terrorist
groups like al qaeda from operating in
the country
and the pentagon announced a reduction
in forces and withdrawal from
five afghanistan bases on july 14th
the fact that trump was willing to break
with bush and obama's policy and go
ahead and negotiate directly with the
taliban
was a clue that he was really serious
but horton says that deal could be
scuttled by allegations that russia paid
bounties to afghanis who killed u.s
troops which prompted republican liz
cheney to partner with several house
democrats to place conditions on the
afghanistan
exit the way it's negotiated is
okay we'll withdraw over the next year
if trump is unelected in the fall
then it would be the new biden
government presumably
to come in and be in charge of
implementing that withdrawal
through next may and so that's plenty of
time really not just for biden but even
for trump if he's reelected
to go ahead and back down once he's
safely reelected
assume one thing blows up over there and
then all they have to say
is you know what circumstances have
changed whatever it is
and stay horton points out trump has
increased u.s involvement in yemen and
somalia
these are two of america's most horrible
wars and no one pays any attention to
them whatsoever
hundreds of thousands of people have
died mostly because of the famine and
the difficulties
and it is a war that is designed
deliberately to inflict as much
punishment as possible on the civilian
population of the country
deliberately targeting water electricity
sewage
hospitals and farms anything that is to
support
the infrastructure of civilian life in
that country it's a deliberate medieval
siege
campaign and trump has continued and
escalated the war on terror which could
make the us
susceptible to getting involved in even
more conflicts around the globe
any regime in the world that has a
problem with any of their subjects all
they have to do is call them terrorists
and ask the americans for help and the
americans will come running
iran cannot be allowed to have a nuclear
weapon
trump also undid obama's nuclear deal
with iran and ordered a targeted
assassination of iranian general
kasem salamani whom he accused of
plotting an attack on an american base
we took action last night to stop
a war but after iran fired back trump
de-escalated
we did not take action to start a war
the previous year he'd also called off
an air strike planned as retaliation for
a downed drone
administration is going to have to
respond to this or lose a lot of
credibility
and standing in the region and around
the rest of the world look at the
narrative and the agenda in the media
horton says media figures often
criticize trump when he avoids military
action or pulls out troops as he did in
northern syria
the announcement is seen as another blow
to u.s allied
kurdish fighters well this is exactly
what everyone feared a free-for-all in
what was
you know one of the most stable parts in
syria what he's done is greenlighted
turkey green lighted russia
and praise him when he takes military
action
such as firing missiles into a syrian
airfield following reports of a chemical
attack
i am tempted to quote the great leonard
cohen i'm guided by the beauty of our
weapons
donald trump became president of the
united states i think this was actually
a big moment how
dare donald trump tried to end any of
america's wars
tried to get out of syria twice and they
went to a full jihad against him to
force him to stay
and he backed down both times
one group of scientists believes trump
has pushed the world closer to nuclear
war
citing his withdrawal from the iranian
nuclear deal and
two russian nuclear treaties as reason
to move the atomic doomsday clock
closer to midnight and russell worries
about the increasingly belligerent
rhetoric on both sides of the aisle
towards
china which trump has escalated tensions
with through his trade war
and reported placement of low-yield
nuclear weapons in the region
going to war with china seems like an
extremely bad idea i'm actually more
worried about the democrats long term
hmm why is that they want to surround
russia militarily and then force putin
to resign
back down offer major concessions but
basically do business with the united
states as we see fit
that's the long-term danger but that's
not so much from trump for me the best
aspect of the foreign policy of trump
is he has revealed the mind of the
foreign
policy establishment the way that the
establishment thinks about foreign
policy
and really government workings and the
workings of the state
generally and the worst aspect of the
trump foreign policy
worst aspect of the trump foreign policy
is that he's a mass murderer just like
the rest of them
in the end trump had the power as
commander-in-chief
to start bringing american troops home
but he failed to formulate a coherent
strategy for doing so
we spent eight trillion dollars over 20
years
fighting all these wars and doing
nothing but empower
our governments adversaries the iranians
and their friends and our real enemies
al qaeda and their friends all around
the region and meanwhile
you're telling me we're short on
hospital beds we're short on masks and
gowns for nurses
while you guys are still bombing a rock
for now the 30th
year straight that doesn't have to be
this way it never should have been this
way
we screwed up got the whole 21st century
off on the wrong foot but we didn't need
to we could call the whole damn thing
off now
everybody knows that and just forge that
new consensus
and stick with it it should be easy
because we're right
[Music]
you